[Music]
these are the first five elements of a
number sequence can you figure out what
comes next
there is a pattern here but it may not
be the kind of pattern you think it is
look at the sequence again and try
reading it aloud now look at the next
number in the sequence 3 1 2 2 1 1
pause again if you'd like to think about
it some more
this is what's known as a look and say
sequence
unlike many number sequences this relies
not on some mathematical property of the
numbers themselves but on their notation
start with the leftmost digit of the
initial number now read out how many
times it repeats in succession followed
by the name of the digit itself then
move on to the next distinct digit and
repeat until you reach the end so the
number one is read as one one written
down the same way we write eleven of
course as part of this sequence it's not
actually the number 11 but two ones
which we then write as 2 1 that number
is then read out as 1 2 1 1 which
written out we'd read as 1 1 1 2 2 1 and
so on
these kinds of sequences were first
analyzed by mathematician John Conway
who noted they have some interesting
properties for instance starting with
the number 22 yields an infinite loop of
two twos
but when seated with any other number
the sequence grows in some very specific
ways notice that although the number of
digits keeps increasing the increase
doesn't seem to be either linear or
random in fact if you extend the
sequence infinitely a pattern emerges
the ratio between the amount of digits
in two consecutive terms
gradually converges to a single number
known as Conway's constant this is equal
to a little over 1.3 meaning that the
amount of digits increases by about 30%
with every step in the sequence
what about the numbers themselves that
gets even more interesting except for
the repeating sequence of 22 every
possible sequence eventually breaks down
into distinct strings of digits no
matter what order these strings show up
in each appears unbroken in its entirety
every time it occurs Conway identified
92 of these elements all composed only
of digits 1 2 & 3 as well as two
additional elements whose variations can
end with any digit of 4 or greater no
matter what number the sequence is
seeded with eventually it'll just
consist of these combinations with
digits 4 or higher only appearing at the
end of the two extra elements if at all
beyond being a neat puzzle the look and
say sequence has some practical
applications for example run-length
encoding a data compression that was
once used for television signals and
digital graphics is based on a similar
concept the amount of times a data value
repeats within the code is recorded as a
data value itself sequences like this
are a good example of how numbers and
other symbols can convey meaning on
multiple levels
[Music]
you